got to meet this man on the set of
billions when we did an episode one year
ago he's shot at 1 year ago over this
month and at the time he told me I'm
gonna start a podcast and now it's one
of the most popular podcasts out there
where all podcasts can be gotten Ripper
Magoo is with Bob mentary who is
followed by 2.2 million people on
Instagram to enjoy the fun and frolic
that he brings every single day good to
see you live a lot a lot of 11 year olds
a lot of kids like it's funny cuz when
we when I when I showed up to the set of
billions and all the kids on the set
that's all they wanted to do is talk to
you and when I ver I'm I have somebody
who's a child or a youngster comes up to
me and wants to talk sports do they do
they want to curse with you is that the
way it works first handle how do you
handle the kids Bob when they come up to
you on that note though I took very uh
precautionary steps here to not swear on
your show tell everyone and certainly in
the radio that's what nice crawled and
what's it like ballpoint pen on your
left I really in the green room because
you came in gave me the stare down you
said don't send this up for me
you steer me the eyes you sat me down
you said if you swear you're done so I
am so nervous then I'm gonna drop a bomb
on here so I'm trying so hard not to
swear because in my podcast we're kind
of little vulgar r-rated and then of
course in your Instagram feed swear on
their doing to break it to you I do okay
yeah on occasion okay you'll drop it
yeah you'll drop it
yeah so it says don't swear it says
don't swear yeah within a couple
underlines with a couple underlines just
so we can really drive it home alright
well hopefully you don't have to refer
to the top of your left hand this
interview what was the first video you
ever did so the first video I ever did
was actually I was sitting on a couch
just like this yes and I was next this
guy who I'd never met before it was 2:30
in the morning and I did my like Aaron
Rodgers Tom Brady here on ESPN little
spiel now I used to always do that
little stick with everybody right like I
used to I was caddy in a country club
three years ago and I used to run up to
random members rows caddying for and I
would do my commentator voice so with
the first video that went viral was me
just sitting on a couch doing my
impersonation and yeah it just took off
I woke up the next day and it was like
bling bling bling my phone was going off
and like who died and it was like no my
stuff on fire on your Instagram food on
my or you
well went on it was went my first clip
went viral and like Reddit bro Bob was
not even know what Instagram was three
years ago I had no idea whatsoever I was
caddy and you're counting in Wilshire
Country caddy mr. country club carrying
two golf bags a day 36 holes loop in
your head on loop in my head off just
getting work okay and so one day you do
a video about was it was football
related is what it was it was yeah well
I started off doing video game glitches
so you know when you're playing a video
game and like Madden for instance and a
glitch is when something goes wrong in a
game for anybody doesn't know and so
like Dion Lewis in Madden for some
reason there's a glitch in the game
where he's running down the field he has
no head and the sports announcers like
yeah Dion Lewis scores and touchdown I'm
like wait a minute he has no head like
why is the sports announcer bringing up
the as no head so I was like I started
in video game glitches and then yeah
carried over to NFL at Bob mentoring on
on Instagram and also Twitter right here
on the Rich Eisen show so what's your
team I mean so you're you got like a
specific real team of your own or or
what as far as my rigging interest yeah
New England Patriots diehard diehard
Patriots fan yeah we had a rough year
though losing Josh Gordon Antonio Brown
obviously I don't know what's going with
him he's going off the rails so I know
Edelman's I know Edelman's seen your
videos and all that good stuff and great
so as Brady
have you ever come across Brady I
haven't talked to Brady but I remember I
need I wanted to get Brady's attention
so what I did was I did commentary over
Tom Brady's family dodgeball game and he
did comment on it he was like lol and I
was like made it's from here on out I
made it Brady
acknowledgement the brilliant Brady
thumbs hit lol yes sent it in the
direction of Bob mentoring yes and now
you've made it and it was actually
pretty cool clip two is like his
family's playing dodge ball he was there
gizelle the kids whose father was there
was pretty good did you curse on that
one too oh yeah of course of course a
family friendly I don't give it to Brady
here not whatever
and now as a sport ever told just sport
has told you to knock it off as a sport
ever the league you mean yeah it's an
easy League done that or the g8 tour got
a little mad at me I was bad I was
busting dak Uppal of guys on there
pretty good
yeah and they sent me a scary letter I
just threw it out really official season
actually I think I couldn't tell cuz you
bald it up and threw it PGA Tour see you
later right and then threw it out but uh
no leagues actually like it look it
we're you know they want to make the
game fun more exciting it's kind of a
different alternative way I'm getting
kids to put down Fortnite controllers
and watch football yeah that's you are
you are really doing that I wish I had a
photograph of your face Bob Chris when
we were having I think we're having
lunch mm-hmm you know you know on our
shoot on our billion shoot that we
haven't lunch and I asked you what
Ripper Magoo meant and I wish take a sip
but I just I just I just look at your
hand so I asked you what it meant and
you're the look on your face was just
priceless man and I realized you know
believe Google searches guys don't
believe urban dictionary that's not
gonna sell people yell this now after
drives like what does that like to know
that you're kind of reaching that
dimension of you know kind of viral this
well I plant all those people there but
I mean it's pretty it's pretty cool like
I mean I started off just saying it
joking around and it just shows the
ability that social media has and just
how fast stuff spreads and once a person
says something and it just catches on
and yeah it's just been it's been pretty
nuts well congrats on that as I told you
when we first met and you know literally
you just took a video of us on the set
you tagged me I think I got like 9,000
Instagram followers with about five
minutes your reach and your your
influence is quite significant but you
gotta stay on my good side I got an army
of 12 year old trolls will just come out
that sounds like the worst horror movie
ever
yes what that sounds like who do you
want on your show that you haven't
gotten yet I would like to get I mean
I've obviously Tom Hanks would be
interesting I would like you know Deion
Sanders your buddy yeah you know we've
got some good ones we had Shaquille
O'Neal on their shacks the man we have
Michael Rubin actually coming on today
today right yep come on to our show
today it's a lot of fun you know I've
never get in the podcast world at all I
started doing it you know and my co-host
Timmy bounce back and Lawrence esselman
are great and it's uh I'm looking
forward to hopefully taking your subs I
try to beat you that's it that's my only
goals I want to be higher than you beat
me and watch feet you in the rankings
but I just can't come close on Spotify
Apple all that I didn't know that
close-ish all right so I know you wanted
to do this and I wanted to do this and
Bob we with you here
prior to a big week at the Super Bowl
what do you have over there Chris okay
so obviously you know gambling happens
on the Super Bowl but I've never heard
on the golf course I want to make one
little thing here Doc Rivers be rich we
all play golf Craig Craig so sir this is
a priority of the great Craig's in West
Hollywood yeah he held a gun to my head
yesterday made sure I said Craig's vegan
ice cream so I had to drop it but all I
know is they say that to you that you
got it when you go on the show he was
joking around but anyways I'm trying to
deflect this thing yeah rich was a 12
handicap and I think you shot like 79 it
was very suspect Doc Rivers is bashing
me on your show said I did I screwed up
on the back nine I had a bad back nine
but I had a pretty powerful night no no
I was just to correct the record here
I'm an 18 handicap
I'm even on a horse I'm not a 12 and
I've never shot a 79 in my life and most
certainly did not that day I was a
factor though I was a factor though you
know I came with my callaway clubs and
my my show bag and all that stuff just
to try and you know in
intimidate and then on occasion at the
right time I made the right I made the
right swing you were drilling everything
it was annoying you're making everybody
like who is this guy and then you're
just like so casual about it you just
have the most relaxed demeanor possible
and you're drilling pots and just taking
my money [ __ ] that's it I was just
trying to get through the day without
without stepping all over myself which
is usually it is on the golf course but
at any rate I did enjoy that day do you
have the yes so obviously so prop that's
a huge part for everyone who likes to
gamble on the Super Bowl so we have some
off-the-wall non real football related
props that I just want to get your
thoughts on these Bob do you have any
sort of music music right there first up
and this one's great
Drake likes to insert himself into all
these big championship games will Drake
promote a team on Instagram yes is minus
140 what you think well I say yes he's
always sticking his nose always in
everywhere so I'd say yes I would take
minus 140 right the curse he believed in
the Drake curse yeah I mean well
actually me did didn't they just win the
all the Raptors yes so for like is the
Kardashian curse but they've got the 19
billion dollars as a family collectively
so I think they win I was good when Demi
Lovato's singing the national anthem
will she forget or omit a word from the
anthem yes plus 500 now she's dialed in
they ever bet on themselves on this
stuff can they ever look sabotage I will
give you an answer to this that I guess
they can but it's requested literally by
the NFL to not even go in this direction
look Miami Super Bowl now Miami Super
Bowl Billy Joel was singing the national
anthem right he was in the NFL Network
green room before being brought out to
meet the media on mass and that was the
year that Prince did a halftime and
Prince refused to do the press
conference with the media he said I'm
just gonna go out and play and actually
played a few songs and it was um
amazing amazing but Billy Joel said I'll
do the press conference or he was asking
he said I'll do it and I remember a
member of the NFL PR staff telling Billy
to his face you may be asked how long
the national anthem is we just asked you
to not say anything about it because
people will wager on it and we just
don't want that sort of stuff if that's
okay got it
he gets out there and starts his
preamble saying hey I'm glad to be here
in Miami this is gonna be an honor to
sing the national anthem I think it'll
be about in minute 40 seconds minute 41
or 42 seconds like that's the way
started Billy Joel's like I got your I
got your talk right here so they're told
not to do that right I think they cap
the action to it that most most sites of
limit how much you know they're
professional singers number one and
number two the words are on the stadium
score people forget words I mean then
she's got some real issues there was an
issue a couple years ago when Lady Gaga
McDouble braved double brandies she
double brave land of the free and home
of the brave the brave like she went
second time with the brave and there was
a whole that's what you know you're sick
gambler alright will an animal appear on
the field Kevin Harlan is doing the
radio broadcast yes that's gonna be big
big on Plus 550 well an animal appear on
the field I'm looking at the screen
right here no birds though so they'll
burn so we're talking about cat feet
we're all feet on the ground yes feet on
the ground guard on the bird on the I
mean I don't think so no I think that
they had their stuff together over there
too they will not buy I didn't see a
blackout coming a few years ago either
but slanty Gardens sing okay this is a
great one will d4 line up offsides
during the game that is left to 54 yes
I'm gonna say yes I don't know why I
have no explanation I think well why not
why not that's so wrong that is so
wrong to do this to that guy right now
do you bet on the games no I'm a
National Football League employees
oh sorry right right I don't even know
what you're talking about
you know and by the way whatever funds
we exchanged on the golf course was like
Odell Beckham money it was fun real
money it was not real but at home
anything well any player proposed to his
girlfriend on the field after the game
yes plus 500 oh now the last time
something like this happen was after the
World Series the the Astros won right
remember that didn't somebody propose
and I think she bout she pounded the the
trashcan once for yes into somebody the
Astros no comment on that well we all
love Bregman yeah he's good I know that
so um what do you think you think which
would you take there yes or no I would
take no I would say no this one's great
we know Jennifer Lopez doing the
halftime show
yes how many times will Alex Rodriguez
be shown during the halftime on point
five is the line over point five plus
two thirty over you think he's gonna be
shown I think he's gonna be showing you
no chance this question when you say
halftime show is it during the music
music when they say now ladies and
gentlemen it's time for the Pepsi
halftime show and then BOOM then Menifee
comes on is it part of halftime
performance during the performance meant
to a rod measuring condom he always
finds his way he's very active right now
everywhere in Seoul anything he's gonna
fight his way to be let's broadcast
matter supertruck Fox has nothing to do
with that
who's like dancing on the stage no that
guy gets his way into everything oh my
gosh he's promoting mo beyond Fox's
coverage honest or ease in the crowd or
whatever he's a very busy guy I might
follow obviously rolling on also one
more time because again all right these
are actually do this legit offshore
gaming sites have these currency you
know gambling is getting right now it's
here she's in San City last one yeah
it's Miami
yes it's Super Bowl week some strange
things might happen yeah at night well
any player gets suspended will memory be
involved in strange things that happen
at night in Miami
yes million that's 350 does anyone get
spended does anyone get suspended during
Super Bowl week come on
no I object to this object in Miami
Eugene Robinson have their lockdown yeah
they are locked down where you say so
tells are like $2,500 a piece I went to
last minute Bob if you want a spoon in
Miami just comes through the front door
that's like cranes planes trains and
automobiles now about those Niners
thanks for coming on man you're the man
dude men are calm is how people can get
your apparel correct
WWWE calm Bob Bob memory memory
documentary calm Ripper Magoo's with Bob
memory memory podcast is available where
all podcasts are if you're not following
Bob mentoring on a social media what
your in the extreme minority at Bob
mentary Twitter and Instagram and I'm
sure a million of
things that I'm unfamiliar about good
the big ones the matter thanks for
coming on you're the man thank you Stu
thank you everybody follow Bob mentoring
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app